[موسيقى]
طعام الطائرة
بعض الناس يكرهه بعض الناس يكرهونه في
كلتا الحالتين تعتبر الوجبات جزءًا مهمًا من
أي رحلة طويلة المدى
والتأكد من أن جميع المكونات في
متناول اليد يمثل تحديًا دائمًا لمقدمي الطعام
الذين سيشعرون بالقلق دائمًا في مكان ما
في العالم من خلال  الجفاف من خلال
الفيضانات من خلال نقص العمالة وأيضًا من
خلال الشحن والتأخيرات الأخرى التي
يمكن أن تحدث بهذه الطريقة
لمعالجة هذه المشكلات
تعتقد طيران الإمارات أن الحل يكمن في التكنولوجيا الزراعية ،
لذا نرحب بكم في المزرعة أه لدينا
عرض للمنتجات التي نحن
حاليًا  تنمو هنا في دبي
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة حيث يتم استيراد ما يقرب من 90 في المائة من
المواد الغذائية ، لقد فتحوا
مزرعة عمودية خاصة بهم
أكبر من أربعة ملاعب كرة قدم
مجتمعة وتبلغ قيمتها 40 مليون دولار
أمريكي ، وتقول الشركة إنها الأكبر في
العالم خلفي  في هذه الغرفة ،
لدينا حاليًا 45 ألفًا ونصف ألف
نادي تنمو في جميع أنحاء المنشأة ، وهذا
يزيد عن 1.1 مليون نبتة تنمو في أي وقت
من اللفت إلى الجرجير إلى الخس.
سيتم حصاد أوراقه المنتجة هنا
وإرسالها إلى شركة طيران الإمارات للتموين
وإعدادها في بعض من 200000
وجبة تخرج من هذا المطبخ كل يوم ،
تكون سلسلة التوريد في غضون 12
إلى 24 ساعة من
حصادها على الطبق  أمامهم
سوف يتذوقونها في النضارة التي سيتذوقونها في النضارة أكثر من
زراعة المنتجات المحلية الطازجة ، يتعلق
الأمر بجعل العمليات أكثر استدامة
وتقليل استخدام المياه ،
النظام البيئي للغرفة يسحب فعليًا
حوالي 1500 لتر يوميًا خارج الغرفة
التي يتم إعادة تدويرها بعد ذلك ، ولكن عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالتكاليف ، تقول شركة الطيران إنه لا
توجد مزايا رئيسية ، لكن التكلفة
قابلة للمقارنة مع الواردات حاليًا ،
نعتقد أنه يمكننا تحقيق المزيد من
الكفاءات في الفعالية التي
ننموها حاليًا في هذه الخطوة الأولى
نحو تغيير ما نحن "  تُظهر إعادة القيام هنا
اليوم أن الاستدامة
يمكن أن تكون في صميم زراعة
المنتجات الطازجة في الشرق الأوسط ، فهي
تشير إلى تطور جين جديد  حصص التكنولوجيا
الزراعية
من سلسلة التوريد الأكثر استقرارًا إلى
الإنتاج الغذائي المستدام للشركات الأخرى ،
يمكن أن تكون المزرعة العمودية لخطوط طيران الإمارات غذاءً
للتفكير وللركاب يمكن أن
تلعب وجبتك دورًا في مستقبل
الزراعة سببًا آخر لتناول
الخضروات آنا ستيوارت  CNN
أجنبية